olivier bonnel journaliste bonsoir
olivier bonnel merci d'être avec nous
cette possibilité de régularisation de
200 milles sans papiers on nous aurait
dit cela il ya encore quelques mois
d'envisager cette solution ne l'aurais
pas cru est ce que la crise sanitaire
clairement est-elle en train d'
infléchir la politique migratoire
italienne alors c'était un petit peu tôt
pour en parler ce soir mais toujours est
il que 200 milles ça correspond à un
chiffre est même très important ça
correspond surtout justement on manque
de main d'oeuvre dans la filière
agricole italienne vous l'avez dit une
filière qui ne fonctionne qui fonctionne
en large partie grâce à ces travailleurs
immigrés alors beaucoup viennent
d'afrique beaucoup viennent aussi des
pgc le gouvernement italien est en train
de travailler un décret justement pour
régulariser 200 milles sans papiers
c'est un décret qui est est en train
d'enquêter à l'étude qui devrait exister
dans l'est dans les prochains jours du
ministère de l'intérieur du ministère du
travail et du ministère de l'agriculture
parce que aujourd'hui sur les tables des
italiens on a besoin de fruits de
légumes et que souvent ces fruits et
légumes sont récoltées par ces
populations de migrants prennent le cas
échéant qu'elle pourrait être selon vous
la réaction des italiens on les a vus
plutôt remonté sur cette question il est
encore quelques mois quand on connaît la
situation des frontières comme lampedusa
quelles pourraient être les réactions à
ce que les états d'esprit on peut être
évolué depuis ce temps là mais c'est sûr
que la question a toujours été assez
délicate elle est délicate pour deux
raisons la première c'est parce qu'elle
a été instrumentalisé par certains
partis politiques
notamment l'extrême droite matteo
salvini en avait fait un de ces de ses
chevaux de bataille si j'ose dire
aujourd'hui on voit que la ligue le
parti de monsieur salvini comme le parti
fratelli d'italia de giorgia meloni qui
monte dans les sondages est vent debout
contre la possibilité évidemment de
régulariser ces étrangers l'autre
l'autre opinion dont on parle beaucoup
ici c'est qu'on a besoin de cette main
d'oeuvre
cette manoeuvre elle fait partie du
paysage si j'ose dire sociologique de
l'italie notamment dans les régions du
sud la campanie la basilicate et les
pouilles où on récolte beaucoup
justement de de fruits et de légumes et
beaucoup d'italiens voit quand même ces
gens d'un bon oeil ils comprennent
qu'aujourd'hui on dans ces temps de
crise avec ses pics annuels ne serait
pas forcément inutile de régulariser ces
personnes qu'elle est aujourd'hui parce
qu évidemment crise du corona virus
oblige on en parle beaucoup mais quelle
est la situation de ces migrants en
italie est ce qu'ils restent enfermés
dans des camps par exemple aller serait
difficile depuis de nombreuses années
puisque ces gens n'ont pas de statut
légal pour la majorité d'entre eux ils
vivent en effet dans des camps que ça
soit en calabre
[Musique]
tarot ou dans les pouilles comme je
disais tout à l'heure sont des gens qui
sont vulnérables qui sont souvent aux
mains des mafias locales
il a c'est un vrai problème mais depuis
des années en italie à la question du
caporal à le fait que les mafias se
servent d'hommes de main pour employés
au noir
c'était personnes là et ces gens là qui
sont en italie qui sont toujours en
italie vivent encore certains dans des
camps wever dans les grandes villes à
mendier alors il ya tout un réseau sont
évidemment de deux ong d'associations
caritatives qui prennent soin d'eux pour
bien que mal malgré la difficulté de
cette crise sanitaire
il ya quelques semaines début avril il
ya une
une plateforme qui s'est créé de
cranberries pour récolter des fonds pour
ces migrants pour ces travailleurs
saisonniers qui travaillent dans les
champs qui vivent de manière très
difficile merci beaucoup olivier bonnel
journalistes pour évoquer donc la
situation en italie merci